on tue la vue oui oui oui oh mais ils
sont deux à pas t'es pas du point y'a
pas à charge
j'étais nerveux
hamon pour chiens quelle vie
me tiens c'est dalmatiens qui cherche
fsi lapin dans le jardin sans les
trouver n'est autre que le chien de
claude rich
avec 100 m nous avons tenté d'éclaircir
le mystère qui plane sur sa personnalité
comment avez vous nommez votre chien
wagner c'est par dérision ou par
admiration pour ce compositeur
séparation pour le compositeur et c'est
surtout parce que je suis alsacien et
que wagner ça sonne bien
il a quel âge il ya sept ans il ya sept
ans il est né dans une boucherie
j'ai tout petit il avait minuscules
comme comme deux points il était tout
petit heures il a été très nerveux au
début du mois c'est une race qui est
toujours un peu nerveuse affectivement
très très sensible et on l'a presque
élevé au biberon c'est assez vraiment
l'enfant la famille et avant vous aviez
d'autres dalmatiens quand j'ai passé
d'artois c'était très gentil mais le
contraire de celui là pas effectif du
tout achat courant qui se sauvait alors
et des partis chez les veaux hamad ont
dit que l'animal ressemblent souvent son
maître ce que vous trouvez qui vous
ressemble sa principale qualité c'est la
fidélité la désobéissance et ses traits
de caractère c'est l' angoisse sachia
comme tous les chiens ils ont une espèce
d'angoissé retiennent la vie ils doivent
savoir des choses que nous pressentons
et que ça sûrement
est ce qui vous arrive d'en mener wagner
au théâtre oh non enfin je les ai déjà
emmené mais il est pas très sage au
théâtre il est blanc et il bouge partout
il renifle ils cherchent des odeurs de
d'autres chiens et il y en a pas
beaucoup alors j'ai peur clic ibis
partouche malgré l'opinion de son maître
wagner est venu ce jour là dans les
coulisses rien
c'est ainsi qu'il a pu assister aux
préparatifs de l'entrée en scène et
constater que même lorsqu'il ne pleut
pas dehors
on peut toujours avoir son costume ou y
est lorsque la pièce l'exigent
là combien
en ce moment vous jouez une perte de la
vue une pièce dont vous êtes l'auteur on
peut vous demander quel en est le sujet
s'est très c'est très sale mais c'est
très compliqué je peux pas raconter
comme ça c'est l'histoire de trois
hommes trois hommes pas le troisième
dans un bateau trois hommes dans un
bureau sur le plus gros oui
oui la veste au site
et
tout est un peu gros oui ça ne vous
plaît pas au super bien maintenant le
pantalon il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas où sont les lieux vous plaît les
lieux oui pour changer mon pantalon se
presser règne pas voir arriver une chose
à moi pendant cette opération se serait
en effet déplorable
j'aurais pu téléphoner mais la neige
s'est mise à tomber
l'important ce n'est pas tellement ce
que se disent les gens c'est des choses
qui ne disent pas et je m'amuse avec ses
personnages de montrer qu'ils sont dans
des situations qui font rire tu crois
que la pièce est le chien et d'écouté
théâtre l'achat d'acteur c'est noir n'en
peux plus d'entendre les jours de
relâche est ce que quand même vous
occuper un peu de wagner ahmed occupent
tout temps et tout ça avec moi il ne me
quitte pas je veux dire il l'a vécu tout
ça toute ma vie je vais dans un quoi
n'importe où il est su
elle s est quelquefois très charmant et
quelquefois un petit peu collant quoi et
à pokola
colchiques dans les prés fleuris le rif
colchiques dans les prés c'est la fin de
l'été
la faille d'autant emportée par le vent
en rhône meaux
l'automne dans
bantoure but ou non
nuages dans le ciel ces tirs ont fait
pire nuages dans le ciel
cette ire com
spy dodo
c'est pas bon
henrot le monde
le tombeau tokyo